welcome to this video playing am van
nostrand do I know the name nope okay
let's see we get a scotch check playing
my wacky Bishop before check line yeah
mmhmm yeah I don't really know I think
it isn't g6 right I mean I played g6 in
a recent game okay let's just take it
play it simple 97 is really nothing
great yeah he gets he gets this end know
which is quite quite nice for white mmm
is there some way to generate quicker
counter play here I wonder mmm the whole
thing is a bit slow here is a bit slow
for wide I mean Knight takes e4 is
definitely a bit bit weird can i play
with with Queen h4 attainted so it's not
it's not really great in terms of
centralizing pieces
I don't know Queen d2 yeah probably i
have to have to play one of those
slightly slightly passive setups yeah he
always has this d 5 square that that's
nice for wide I wonder can I get an f5
somehow and I will play 95 very very
shortly 5s is hard to play really 95 85
this kind of stuff why just enjoys the
some advantage in space and it's not
going to going to get away quickly
hmm
huh not not easy here not easy Queen g5
that's just castling and this leads
nowhere okay I put this here maybe i can
i can play stuff like that f6 bishop f7
96-94 that's a somewhat somewhat strange
idea but maybe it's working getting
getting a night to deform I wouldn't
mind to play c5 even then to support it
okay so he's not reminding it that much
I mean I couldn't do much about it
probably c6 to get the night away a half
night f4 here even I mean or is this a
weird idea I in any case I don't know I
fc5 maybe a 6b five it's not that bad
probably okay i will lend support to the
night now f4 yeah okay i have half g
five as well it's not it not ok it is a
tricky square as it has no I can still
cannot go there h Freud is trapped hmm
as a thought I should counter a check
only for but oh ok yeah let's let's
let's try this anyway try for be five if
i play it now can I do that at the end
there is night f5 right that's not good
okay maybe the Queen can irritate him
I'm glad that she put the rook away from
f1 so it's not that likely that
something is happening on the king yeah
but if I've something like a five is
also quite interesting opening up the
whole the whole position okay he might
have before now we have undermining
undermining my night hmm ok well so I
can just drop back in to the aid let's
let's let's just returned come on I'm
falling behind on the clock quite
considerably ok I need to get rid of the
night there is no way around that
that's it sits trade at least one one of
the nights Wow okay okay want to be
quick em now you're not playing for draw
here right no okay what what he played
is definitely possible but probably not
totally convincing I mean this might be
vague compensation but it's not better
for white i'm pretty sure i have queen a
5c 5 stuff like that and it's not so
clear what his plan is going to be 35
stuff like that maybe catch check-in and
quincy form turn activate ok he will
probably go with e 5 but ok i put it is
got rooked you mon yeah but i don't i
don't know i don't think II five is so
dangerous actually can still easily
capture may be here time warning just
keep stuff protected and maybe a techie
form it's not so easy to to do is to to
do anything the other I am okay if I
take no I can go back here so I can take
him I can go back or is f5 so so great
okay i will play it anyway
not not much to be done here f5 might be
might be a move but i can i can take on
each women and yeah i mean that that
shouldn't really we know anything f5 I
don't think so okay if I take e to n I
take e to Queen geforce also possible
that it takes Queen at six yeah let's do
that 25 seconds check 94 is tricky
21 seconds hmm
check okay he's spending some time
keeping an eye on one on the pawn he
threatened Quincy aid unfortunately wow
thats it's very difficult to play check
now k at the end I'm even I'm drawing
again drawn well just about eliminating
the last porn yeah wow this was
difficult it was very tricky i think
around here i should win somehow but I
couldn't really figure it out it's of
course not so easy with the time I
probably yeah I should have taken you I
wasn't totally sure what about this but
rook takes g2 is that he move ok I know
I see you know I see I can I am ok what
I didn't see is that after i thought
after King takes I have no check so I
can take care of course you can take him
and this will save the day I can I can
get all those checks Jack and at the end
take him which wins easily ok so that
means after rook takes he has to capture
app ok if this is forced then I'm of
course winning here because I can just
take him and take now and now the night
is not doing anything and the rook is
gone which is
important yeah yeah I'm winning quite
quite simply ya there yeah I couldn't
really figure it out I didn't see that I
was of course considering this but here
I didn't see that I can take I mean I
saw her I can take but I thought rook
takes and I don't know what to do then
because he is threatening this with a
mate ok so i went here check and yeah
this is this is a very tricky play I
guess black should be better but but how
do how to win yeah with this time
difficult the comp is just giving black
a fled win but it's not easy to do yeah
Queen f6 mm-hmm I am who came this is in
fact click click not that difficult I'm
going Queenie 5 and yeah he of course he
cannot take i just take this okay yeah
okay well i didn't have any time i
actually glad that i could could draw I
mean this was was kind of shy and kind
of difficult to play lost a couple of
moves here of course but I care at five
seconds so somewhere around shi'ites
it's probably maybe there was wind
somewhere for wide around here around
here black wins again but okay I hear
white could win how exactly with a five
yes of course a5 is stronger this
prevents me from getting a possum and
wins yeah this is actually also winning
with precise play if he takes me five
first but ok it was a total time
scramble or maybe the draw is a fair
result at the end I don't know yeah I
hope you enjoyed it was a good fight at
least thanks for watching